30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes
10 minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get filled on the app store or google
play hi everyone it's joanna here i am
super excited today because i have my
favorite
kickboxing instructor with me marco some
of you might have seen him or even tried
his workouts on field app
if you haven't you are missing out so be
sure to
so download today it's going to be a
really fun
high-energy partner kickboxing workout
correct
yeah and trust me guys he is going to be
kicking
your ass so what are we going to do
today
okay so what we're going to do is going
to be a partner workout we're going to
try to try the basic movements
punches with defense okay
from here we're going to alternate with
some intensity in between and we are
going to finish
this with some core workout so you will
feel your abs burning okay
so it is a total body workout don't
worry if you don't have a partner you
can still do this workout
you can do this as a partner or you can
just alternate the exercise
on the next minute so you can do it by
yourself or with your partner
but you will feel it alright let's
get punching
are you guys ready joanna ready i am
ready we are going to start with a bit
of warm up so just to put your heart
rate up so let's
start here with a bit of bug kick butt
kicks that's it
remember this is gonna be a partner
workout so we are going to be
alternating exercises
and we are going to do some intensity in
between get ready for that
so now from here highness we're going to
use also this movement so let's
warm up our legs keep it up keep it up
and from here we're going to do some
jumping jacks let's put the heart rate
up three
two and one let's go
easy movement here that's it
today we're going to practice the basic
basic
defensive movements on the kickboxing
we're going to do some sleeps
we're going to do some underducks and
blocks
from here let's skip the rope imaginary
rope
just easy side to side
imagine that you have your rope good job
three two and
one shake it out and let's do just some
movements with your hips
we're going to do a squat and twist
we're going to start to the twist on the
left ready
and one squat twist the right to the
left squat
to the right easy movement here just
to warm up our hips remember unboxing
we just pivot your ankles all the time
three
two and one let's get ready what we are
going to do today we are going to do
three different rounds one focus in your
upper body
one sec the second one on your lower
body and the third one is gonna be for
your abs okay
so basic movements if you are first time
boxing
this is gonna be interesting for you
step together one step to the right
want to step back 45 degrees on your
feet
feel a stable feel comfortable on your
toes hands up
and from here we are going to throw jab
which is your left
and cross that is your right okay we are
going to switch
hand and hand okay what we are going to
do minute one
one person is gonna throw the punches
while the second or your partner is
gonna just slip
the movements remember you are trying to
cover or
like to sleep the punch with your elbow
up with your shoulder up okay
so move side to side rotation on your
hips so minute one
i will do it i will throw the punches
joanna will
slip and then we will switch in between
we will have
30 seconds when we are going to do some
speed punches okay so it's gonna be
simple it's gonna be easy
so let's get ready for this we have 20
more seconds
and let's practice this jab cross your
main punches
and your sleep on the left on the right
okay this is gonna be the first one
let's get ready for that second minute
we're going to do
left hook right hook and your partner
will do the underdog important thing
facing your opponent
let's get ready here i will start here
jab cross
that's it good job important thing
moving your body good job
twisting your arms twisting your hips
good job
it's gonna be a bit of cardio here but
we're going to keep moving your legs all
the time
good job if you don't have a partner
first minute
throw jab and cross and ensure that you
master this movement one hand punch one
hand
cover okay we have 20 more seconds
let's get ready for this good job
easy movement here straight arms and
let's get ready 10 more seconds
and we will go with the speed punches 30
seconds to the front
10 seconds to go almost there keep it up
keep it up
three two and one let's get ready
spit punches to the front
good job good job speed speed speed
and from here what we're going to do
we're going to switch
so now i will do the sleeps your partner
will throw
the punches 15 seconds keep it up keep
it up
ten more seconds here faster faster
faster
five four almost there
three two shake it out
now from here you wanna throw the
punches and i sleep
good job always
focus looking at your opponent good job
twisting your hips your shoulder is
coming up to protect your chin
okay good job you have two
options you can throw your hand down you
can keep
your hand up okay it's up to you however
you feel more comfortable
as long as you put your shoulder up to
cover your jaw
30 more seconds good job
we're almost there keep it up keep it up
15 more seconds and we're going to get
into uh speed punches again
three not yet not yet
two almost and
that's it speed punches again to the
front
good job the second
exercise that we're going to do we're
going to throw
left hook and right hook while your
partner
will do an underdog important thing
always look at your opponent almost
there
ten more seconds keep it up
five four three
two and shake it out so from here stand
in front of your partner
you're to the left yes and your partner
moves to the right
throw your punch good job 90 degrees on
your shoulder
on your elbow and your partner looking
at you
that's it remember if you don't have a
partner
minute one go to your left hook and
right hook
twist your arms twist your body
your second minute will be your underdog
if you don't have a partner
it's easy and here we are rotating all
the time
your hips your core so it's a nice
workout for your core
that's it one hand punch
one hand up good job 15 more seconds
good job under under
almost there 10 more seconds and from
here
we go to uppercuts with the speed in
three
into in one from here
roll your shoulders we're just going to
put some cardio here roll your shoulders
that's it faster movement on your
shoulders
and now i will do the underdog while
joanna will be throwing
left hook and right hook okay let's get
ready let's get ready
ten more seconds remember twisting
your hips you will do one slightly one
step to the side
two avoid the punch three two one in
front of your partner
so down and down that's it
now you are squatting a bit moving
side to side good job
always looking at your opponent good job
that's it easy
30 more seconds move to the side
and to the side good job that's it you
can move
all the time this is just to avoid
when somebody's gonna make you a side
punch
good job 15 more seconds
good keep it up keep it up twist your
hips you will feel now in your core
in your legs five more seconds almost
there
and we are coming back to 30 seconds
off speed punches on their uppercut
faster movement here
from here we're going to have our last
two minutes
a bit of workout with a strength we are
going to do
10 mountain climbers and one push-up
and then we will have 30 seconds
recovery so let's get ready for this
for this 10 more seconds faster roll
your shoulders
and let's get ready 10 mountain climbers
on your plank
one push up three two let's go to the
floor
plank position one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten and one
push up
one more time four five six seven
eight nine ten one push up
that's it easy
and push up one two three four
five six eight nine ten push up
almost there we have 30 seconds to go
eight nine ten and push up good job
contract your core four six eight
ten push up one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
push up one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten push up
the last time one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten one more
push up
and now we have 30 seconds recovery
how is it good yes getting some sweat
here
20 more seconds recovery and let's do it
again last one time
you guys ready 10 mountain climbers one
push up
now it's our time to work out in your
core and the strength
of your upper body ready i'm gonna do it
and push up on the knees
just in that's the variation if you feel
tired go to your knees
your hips to the front and calm down
with your chest let's go
one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten put your knees down come
down to the floor
that's it plank position go to your
height
to mountain climbers whenever you have
ten
knees down up that's it four
five six seven eight nine ten and push
up
one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten contraction in your car
all the time
three four five six seven eight nine
ten one push up one two
three four five six seven nine
ten push up we have twenty more seconds
almost there come on come on come on
john
three four down
ten more one two three four five six
seven nine ten one push up
and break it out let's have one minute
break
drink some water you guys i am feeling
sorry
feeling the burn feeling the morning
that's it one minute break here
and now we are going to work out on your
legs so what we are going to do
is starting on the right side we are
going to be alternating your legs
you will face your partner so i will do
one reverse
and we come in with a kick front kick
reverse launch front kick okay
so this is gonna be our first minute we
are going to be alternating your legs
okay let's get ready so minute one
i will do on the right minute two
johanna will do
on the right okay so we will have one
minute each side
in between we're going to take it easy
this time we're just going to move
your butt kicks in your resting time
okay
you guys ready ready let's get some
space let's get
do it makes your space three two
hands up reversed and kick
reverse kick important thing
your feet is up your hand is down good
job
that's it reverse lunge
and front kick good job
your left hand or your opposite hand to
your leg
is just covering your face all the time
you will feel the born in your legs that
is good this is what we want
nice workout with your special one
or even with your friends let's go
keep it up here 20 more seconds
almost there and from here we're going
to switch
to bot kicks slowly 10 more seconds on
your rears
almost there
five more seconds keep it up keep it up
three
two the last one boom now
here just easy this is just to recover
we just move your legs option just like
slowly tap your feet this is just to
release
the acid lactic on your legs so we are
going to get ready for your second round
reverse lunge and front kick
10 seconds to go you guys ready
make some space and let's do it in three
in two and opposite hand lay now
boom okay this is gonna be more
challenging for me
i have less balance on this side let's
do it
remember if you are with your partner
switch
the sides if you are long you can do
one minute on the right one minute on
the left
that's it play it with your hands your
opposite hand
now it's covering your face all the time
push
that sit reverse and push
good job if you have seen my feeling
my feel we use the push kick
so now it's time for us to practice
10 more seconds almost there
almost there ten more seconds ten more
seconds
let's go let's go easy five
four three
two last one boom and from here just
last
release the power on your legs easy
movements here
if you feel a bit of challenge for
yourself make your butt kicks
if you want just to relax move your legs
next movement we're going to do we're
going to do
an squat and i will throw a kick
joanna will block the kick okay one
squat
and one kick for the second minute we
are going to switch and she will be
kicking okay
ready let's go starting this side right
kick and block switching your legs good
job
kick and she blocks good job
i kick she blocks working on your legs
good job the partner who is blocking
is working on the abs while
the kicker is working slightly on the
left
on the legs let's go good job here
twist your hips twist your legs
30 more seconds good job
elbow always up when you block your
knees coming up to your elbow
that's it on your kicks twist your body
your hand is coming down so you can just
twist your hips five more seconds
three two
and one same thing here let's release
your legs
that's it easy moves release your
release your legs you can tap your legs
a bit
that's it warning yeah absolutely
burning
and balance as well good now it's my
turn to work out in my core
so i will be blocking the johanna's kick
okay
now if you are with your partner time to
switch
ready three two
your first kick here squat block
squat block your knee all the way up to
your elbow with your blocking
good job your toes pointing the floor
your hands covering your face good job
looking good
that's it this is a very basic movement
on kickboxing
a kick and a block we have 30 more
seconds
and we are working hard in those hours
that's
it
good job good job almost there we have
20 more seconds
almost there 15 more
don't rest now let's go up and up
contraction on your side
ten more seconds almost there come on
joanna
three two last one
boom let's release your legs all the way
here
this is an active recover okay
now we are getting into our last two
minutes
so what we are going to do i will start
moving my high knees up while joanna
will be just holding
the squat okay so after the second
for the second minute we are going to
change the position okay
let's get ready cardio for one
endurance for the partner let's go here
and i move
with my knees up and joanna holding the
squat
remember keeps down and
keeps up here good job that's it
easy easy come on joanna if you are with
your partner just cheer her up
come on joanna keep going hi knees after
the burn
we are feeling the board with you guys
fire
30 more seconds and now my next
is gonna be holding my squad i hope
i will do it as good as joanna is doing
now you have
20 more seconds and we are going to rest
30 seconds
almost there come on 10 more seconds
here
almost almost keep moving keep moving
that's five five four
three two thirty seconds rest
that's it good job
now it's my turn i will be holding my
squad
and joanna will be doing the high knees
same thing if you have not a partner now
just
you can switch your minutes okay one
minute you do your holding
one minute you do your high knees let's
get ready
i hope i will do it as good as you wanna
come with me
whoever is coming down holding a squat
let's go bring your knees up
knees up good job
pace your breathing inhale from your
nose exhale from your mouth and keep
your hips lower if you are with me
that's it look at this we are on fire
now
we have 40 more seconds almost there and
we are going to get one minute rest
we really deserve it
come on come on come on we got this 30
more seconds
keep your hips lower stable position
almost there
come on joanna only 20 more only 20
seconds
everybody let's go let's go
15 more come on come on come on
10 more seconds everyone come on joanna
five four three
two and that's it good job
high five here that's it
that was intense it was intense we have
now one more minute for west
drink some water if you need and we are
going to get ready
for some abs workout okay so we are
going to do
one minute exercise and we are going to
have 30 seconds recovery for
your core so total we're going to get
into six
new exercises for your core this is
gonna be as well you can do it with your
partner
or you can just do it by yourself it's
gonna be nice
and it's gonna be in your core totally
totally
feeling okay so let's get ready the
first one
we're going to make some space out and
from here we're coming into your
inchworm position
one two three four steps and we clap one
two three and four we crawl back
and we put hands up okay this is gonna
be our first minute
are you ready i am up some fire in three
two let's go one two three
four one two three four
walk back and hands up coming in
one two three four one two
three four walk back
hands up one more time in in in
in one two three and four
walk your hands back hands up halfway
we have 30 seconds already done good job
with this exercise we are moving or we
are
doing a mobility in your core so we are
extending on the way down
and we are contracting your core on the
way up
extend again one more time almost there
one two three four
walk your hands back up and the last one
one two three four one two
three and four thirty seconds rest
good job and we are starting to feel
your abs
okay the next one we are going to sit
it's gonna be easy
so what we are going to do we are going
to interlace your hands
your legs so i will go up and joanna is
coming up
and down we are going to be in and out
okay
let's get ready for this important thing
put your hands next to your hips
and extend and contract your abs as long
as you move your legs together okay
ready i'll start up three two up and
down extension
and contraction with your knees good job
extending your legs
contracting your knees play with the
rotation of your core here
in and out good job
warning now
yeah you feeling it we are definitely
but we want that beachbody okay everyone
here we are going to do it we get some
apps
let's go 20 more seconds
in and out and then we have 20 seconds
30 seconds recovery
okay almost there come on come on come
on
come on see i am dying keep it up in and
out
10 more
my seconds are shaking legs are shaking
abs are shaking
but we have five four three
two one that's it one minute break
rest rest rest shake your legs
and now next one we are going to get
into a plank position
low plank position and we will clap your
partner okay
one and one you ready we are going to
rest we are going to rest your legs now
we are we are going to wrestle your legs
now
so get into your plank not yet okay
let's rest a bit
everybody five more seconds ready
three two one plank position
and just keep clapping your partner
you can have a nice story here with your
partner
you can just thinking why you are doing
this
what are we gonna have a dinner later
yeah exactly what's going to be the
dinner what's going to be the next lunch
just keep working plank position
extension on your hand
and always try to keep your hips as the
same
in the same position all the way here
high
breathe yeah keep it up we are sweaty
almost there we have 20 more seconds
good job 20 more almost
now now we have our 2020
one abs resolution so keep it up
three two and one
good job 30 seconds recovery
and now we're going to do a rainbow
while your partner will be a side to
side move
okay so sit in front of your partner
so joanna will be moving her legs side
to side
contracting the core and doing the
rotation side to side
while i'm doing an over rotation here in
a rainbow move okay is there an
easier option you can tap the floor
moving top moving top just in case
let's go side to side i will be doing
the rain bone
the idea is to don't put your feet down
but the option you can tap here and then
come up
and tap come up and tap this is another
option
okay always remember we have options for
you guys
so they the only option that we don't
have is to rest
when we don't need okay keep it up stop
on top
30 more seconds almost there
bring your core up remember tapping and
tapping is an option
let's go challenge is going up
almost there joanna come on show those
apps
10 more seconds
10 more almost there five
four three
two and one
good job feeling it i am so feeling it
just in case you guys didn't know this
is like our third workout today
that's it i'm dying all filmed in real
time
all for you guys yeah come and join us
again
we have now 10 more seconds recovery now
joanna will do the rainbows
remember your option you can tap the
floor up and tap
up and tap i will be doing just side to
side okay
ready three two one let's go here
all the way that's it option easy
tapping and it's a spill a lot of
workout i can tell you
don't feel that it's not working
definitely it's gonna work a lot of
movement in your core
contraction all the time
that's it let's go already doing the
option
take it easy take it easy 30 more
seconds
good job take your time you can hold it
yes you can help your partner here so
you can hold your step
i can hold the legs here that's it this
should be nice
good job you know it's not easy
it is through the workout
10 more seconds good fun it's good fun
it's a good morning on your abs
last five seconds come on three
two and break
30 seconds shake it out check it out
and we have one more and we're going to
work out in the
full rotation of your abs we're going to
be doing circles
are you ready for this we're going to
interlace your legs circles i will do
circles to the right joanna will be to
the left 30 seconds and we will switch
i might ruin those circles
i can hold it i can hold it i can hold
that's why it's a partner workout i can
i can work for it three what are we
doing two i will go to the right
you go with your left to the left yeah
that's it
extend your legs i'll do the right
johanna is doing the left that's it
almost there this is easier as expected
right
10 more seconds we are going to switch
the sides i will go to left
johanna to the right ready you will
switch in three
into let's go opposite side
let's go good job
we have 20 more seconds only come on
come on joanna come on
keep going give it up
okay ten more seconds whenever you can
i'm finding the loop three two
ten seconds to go contraction in your
core your legs are burning
our legs are boring as well three two
last one and that's it
oh my gosh feel your abs burning i told
him
not to kill me and guess what
you did kill me you did an amazing
workout so now we are
filling the abs and i hope you guys are
feeling as well your abs
so let's just cool down a bit drink some
water inhale from your nose
exhale from your mouth catch your breath
and whenever you are ready
join us for a slightly a bit of cool
down
so if you guys are ready let's step
front
and let's catch some air from down
inhale
keep it in and now interlace your hands
go up
as high as you can three two and
one bring your hips back and your arms
to the front
five four three
two one open up your legs your compass
and try to come slightly lower with your
hips three
two one maintain your left hand in the
front
and your right hand moving to your left
toes
feel the stretching in your abs after
the workout we did with the abs
now this is gonna feel nice three two
and one reset your hands in the middle
and now switch your hands
three two
and one hands in the middle again
and now both hands will be moving to
your right ankle
in three into let's go
to the right side feel the stretching in
your lats
in your right side three two
and one move your hands all the way to
the left
and right get your left ankle here five
four three two
and one put your hands down in the
middle
three two and one and walk your feet
slightly closer so from here
we're going to walk your hands and we're
going to drop
your knees down from here put your knees
down
put your pelvis down and slightly put
your chest to the ground
release your hands in the front clap
your hands on your back
and now put your hands next to your
shoulder closer to your chest
and bring your chest up into your cobra
pose
go as high as you can push
your pelvis down so you can feel the
stretching in your lower abs
three two and one twist your body to the
right
five four three
two and one move your to your body to
left
three two and one and from the center
now
into your tabletop position bring your
hips back
sit on your heels and walk your hands to
the front
feel the stretching in your shoulders in
your arms
lower back and your glutes hold this
position
three two and one
get up in your tabletop in your plank
with your toes up
and walk your hands all the way to your
hands
inhale cut some air
and exhale one more time inhale
and the last one inhale bring your hands
up
put your hands up bring your hands all
the way down to your chest
give yourself a round of applause clap
your hands with your partner
and thank you thank you so much joanna
thank you so much marco
you know if i can't complete a workout
that this workout
is intense okay but the burn is good
you're gonna feel it in your legs your
abs and even your upper body if you love
marco's workout remember to check out
more of his workout on view alright
and we will see you next time and let me
know in the comments below how you felt
all the best lots of thumbs up and
punches okay in the comments below bye
thank you
thank you